hello and welcome to the shaky sign
shame are you looking for some mundane
motivation or maybe you're watching us
on a David isn't Monday I just want some
motivation anyway well no problem
because there's gonna be some motivation
in this video so for the next 12 weeks
or maybe longer we are all safely
distancing and so got me thinking twelve
weeks is a perfect time to start a 12
week challenge so since probably around
85% of this time will be spent indoors
this means that many cards are pretty
much off the table with regards to
setting a challenge but there are so
many things that you can do that are in
sides during this time instead which
I'll discuss some ideas later on in the
video as she can achieve quite a lot
within a 12 week time span so what do I
plan to do in my 12 week challenge well
me being me has set more than one
challenge but the first one is to grow
this channel after these 12 weeks I
would have been doing this for over a
year and so it'll be nice to grow my
count and secondly I'd like to do 30
push-ups in a room well we'll see how
that goes
I'd also like to write up all of my lab
results so far which i think is actually
important and another challenge is to
maybe try and read a book each week so
that be 12 new books they'll get to read
so what challenges can you do so maybe
there's always been a recipe that you
wanted to master or maybe you wanted to
write a book or even just read so many
books as I am trying to do what are you
trying to strike up a conversation each
day with someone you haven't spoken to
in a long time so this would be a non
physical conversation also you might
like to learn the periodic table yeah
this is a science show but my absolute
favorite one is 12 weeks is actually 84
days and so given that there are 20
amino acid structures to learn and 64
different codons that gives you 84 and
so you could learn the structure of an
amino acids or a codon pattern each
thing yay so anyway it's day one what
are you still doing listening to my
video get going and as always thanks for
listening